[Música]
el FBI arrestó a un joven de 21 años
sospechoso de la filtración de
documentos más grave en Estados Unidos
en la última década se trata de un
empleado de la guardia nacional aérea
detenido en Massachusetts a quien se
acusa de haber compartido esta
información confidencial en una
plataforma de mensajería instantánea
por segunda vez y durante más de 7 horas
el expresidente de Estados Unidos Donald
Trump declaró ante la fiscalía general
de Nueva York en el marco de una
investigación civil por supuesto fraude
con sus empresas el comienzo del juicio
para este caso Está programado para el 2
de octubre tenemos el reporte desde la
gran manzana
nuevo capítulo en la crisis carcelaria
en Ecuador tres guardias fueron
asesinadas en un atentado cometido por
presuntos sicarios en Guayaquil esto
ocurre apenas Un día después de la
muerte de seis reos en el pabellón de un
penal de la misma ciudad costera
ampliamos desde quito
Bienvenidos a este resumen informativo
con las noticias más importantes de la
jornada en el continente americano los
acompaña Daniel hablandolo comenzamos
con a noticias del FBI que arrestó a un
joven militar señalado de ser el
principal sospechoso de revelar
información confidencial sobre la guerra
en Ucrania y otros datos delicados
relacionados con varios aliados de
Estados Unidos hasta el momento no se
han podido esclarecer las implicaciones
diplomáticas ni de seguridad Nacional de
las revelaciones pero el presidente Joe
biden hizo un llamado a la calma Andrés
triviño nos amplía
un escándalo de filtraciones el FBI
arrestó a jacteira el principal
sospechoso de filtrar múltiples
documentos clasificados del pentágono
considerado como la mayor fuga de
material confidencial desde el caso de
Wikileaks en 2010 y que tiene a Estados
Unidos y a sus aliados en el ojo del
huracán
el departamento de justicia arrestó a
Jack Douglas en relación con una
investigación sobre la supuesta
extracción retención y transmisión no
autorizada de información clasificada de
defensa nacional compartiendola como
empleado de la guardia Nacional de la
fuerza aérea de los Estados Unidos
los investigadores sospechan que el
detenido fue el responsable de divulgar
información confidencial a través de la
plataforma de mensajería instantánea
discord y fue allí donde se compartieron
datos acerca de la participación de
Estados Unidos y sus aliados de la otan
en la Guerra de Ucrania así como
detalles de sus planes militares la
presión estadounidense a Corea del Sur
para que ofrezca ayuda militar a Ucrania
e incluso información de que la agencia
israelí mossad estaría detrás de las
multitudinarias protestas en contra de
la Reforma judicial que propone Benjamín
netanyahu en su país
tenemos pautas estrictas para
salvaguardar la información confidencial
y clasificada este fue un acto criminal
deliberado una violación de esas pautas
Y nuevamente creo que es importante
entenderlo
ahora se espera que teixeira sea
procesado por un tribunal Federal de
Boston mientras se abre el debate de
como un militar de bajo Rango pudo tener
acceso a una información tan
confidencial
y nos quedamos en ese país pero para
hablar esta vez del ex presidente Donald
Trump quien fue interrogado durante
siete horas por las fiscal general del
estado de Nueva York Letizia James en el
marco de una investigación civil por un
supuesto fraude comercial de más de 250
millones de dólares la demanda acusa a
Trump y a su familia de engañar a bancos
y empresarios al darles información
falsa sobre el valor de las acciones de
sus empresas y hoteles esta vez apenas
una de las varias investigaciones
preliminares en su contra nuestra
corresponsal en Nueva York que mamenzala
nos entregó detalles en el siguiente
informe
Donald Trump ha permanecido durante
siete horas dentro del edificio de la
fiscalía general del estado y al parecer
ha estado contestando a las preguntas
esta vez no habría convocado la quinta
enmienda algo que hizo el pasado agosto
cuando también fue citado por la fiscal
general del estado de Nueva York Leticia
James en ese caso sí que contestó a esas
400 preguntas acogiéndose a la quinta
enmienda pero no esta vez por qué estaba
citado Aquí bien por una demanda civil
que habría presentado la fiscal general
del estado de Nueva York Letizia James
acusándolo a él a la organización Trump
y a tres de sus cuatro hijos de haber
realizado una serie de fraudes de haber
mentido en los informes de haber inflado
sus propiedades en cuanto al valor para
conseguir mayores beneficios Leticia
James ha dicho que esta investigación la
investigación que hay detrás de esta
demanda ha tardado en hacerse tres años
y precisamente comenzó en el 2019 cuando
él es abogado personal de Donald Trump
confesó ante el congreso una serie de
irregularidades en las empresas en aquel
momento Michael cohen dijo que la
organización Trump habría inflado el
valor de algunas de sus propiedades para
obtener como digo mayores beneficios y
habría infravalorado el de otras para
obtener también ventajas Fiscales el
juicio por este caso está previsto que
se celebre el 2 de octubre y en esta
ocasión la fiscal general Leticia James
está pidiendo al juez que
castigue a Donald Trump con una multa de
250 millones de dólares y que le prohíba
volver a trabajar volver a realizar
negocios en el estado de Nueva York
cambiamos de información el dueño de
Twitter elon musk anunció que habilitará
una herramienta para que los usuarios
puedan cobrar por sus contenidos sin
ofrecer mayores detalles El Magnate dijo
en su cuenta personal que Durante los
primeros 12 meses la empresa no retendrá
ningún valor por estas suscripciones
Aunque Apple y Google sí se quedarán con
el 30% por el uso de sus tiendas de
aplicaciones ha venido realizando
cambios para aumentar los ingresos tras
el desplome de la publicidad del año
pasado antes de que comprara la red
social uno de ellos fue el cobro por
tener las cuentas verificadas
y en Ecuador tres guardias de prisiones
murieron mientras departían frente a la
penitenciaría del litoral de Guayaquil
la más grande del país según las
autoridades se trató de un atentado
cometido por presuntos sicarios el
ataque empeora la crisis carcelaria en
esta nación que apenas un día antes se
había exacerbado con la aparición de
seis reos ahorcados en un centro penal
de la misma ciudad nuestro corresponsal
en Quito Gustavo Ortega nos junto
detalles
ocurrió frente a la penitenciaría
electoral en la ciudad de Guayaquil tres
guías penitenciarios que almorzaban en
un comedor frente a una de las cárceles
más violentas del país los guías
penitenciarios fueron asesinados por
impactos de bala y apenas tenían meses
en el cargo A diferencia de uno de ellos
que llevaba 10 años en funciones la
Policía Nacional confirmó que los
custodios del centro penitenciario
fueron asesinados al estilo sicariato y
ya habían recibido amenazas
anteriormente dos guías fallecieron el
lugar y otro fue trasladado herido a un
donde posteriormente Se confirmó de su
fallecimiento el atentado sucedió un día
después que seis cuerpos de reos de la
misma penitenciaría aparecieran colgados
en el pabellón número cinco de la cárcel
de Guayaquil sucede en medio de un
contexto de muertes violentas el crimen
organizado en las calles un ataque
armado que acribilló a los presentes en
el mercado pesquero artesanal de la
provincia costera de Esmeralda una de
las más violentas del país y otros dos
sicariatos en el malecompusoja y el
terminal pascuales de la ciudad de
Guayaquil en el año 2022 Guayaquil ocupó
el número 22 en las ciudades más
violentas del mundo paralelamente el
secretario de seguridad nacional Diego
Ordóñez ha presentado su renuncia en
medio de cuestionamientos a su gestión
el presidente de la república aprobó el
porte de armas regulado para la defensa
de los civiles mientras que las fuerzas
armadas saldrán a las calles en apoyo a
la Policía Nacional sucede De igual
forma cuando Ecuador vive una de las
crisis de seguridad amenazas de bomba y
narcotráfico más violentas de su
historia
y el fondo monetario internacional
recomendó a los gobiernos de
latinoamérica poner en marcha políticas
Fiscales más estrictas que incluyan un
incremento de impuestos a los más ricos
de esta manera según el prestamista
podrían ayudar a los bancos centrales a
contener la alta inflación el organismo
puso especial
énfasis en Chile del que espera un
crecimiento negativo este año y del que
dice necesita una reforma fiscal lo
antes posible el fondo monetario Espera
que los tipos de interés se mantengan
elevados en la región durante gran parte
de este año Incluso en 2024 mientras que
la inflación seguirá en niveles más
altos de lo deseado hasta comienzos de
y el presidente de Brasil y Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva junto con el de Colombia
Gustavo Petro y el Astro argentino
Lionel Messi son algunos de los siete
latinoamericanos presentes en la lista
de las 100 personas más influyentes
según la revista Time Petro y Lula se
encuentran en la categoría de líderes
mientras que me decía aparece en la
sección de Titanes también figuran
personajes como las actrices Salma Hayek
mexicana hizo es Saldaña de la
ascendencia dominicana así como Pedro
Pascal
[Aplausos]
de esta manera llegamos al final de este
resumen informativo de las noticias más
importantes del continente americano
quédense con nosotros en France 24 y en
France 24 punto com
[Música]